Jaakko echo what are your guilty
pleasures other than donuts and by the
way I don't even like donuts that's pure
echo right there yeah you're talking
about yet a doughnut delivery it's sorry
let me finish the question what are you
guilty pleasures other than doughnuts
Jocko what do you do when you
momentarily give in to a vice or
something that you know it's bad for you
men I like I like the fact that the
people that are asking this is actually
two questions in one I appreciate the
fact that this person says jockle what
do you do when you momentarily
give in to advice I appreciate that as
if I'm this person that could only for a
fraction of a moment give in to any form
of vice because I am NOT a human yeah so
I appreciate that you know the part I
appreciate about this too much question
the first part asks both of us
specifically jackal and echo what are
your guilty pleasures the second part
asks other or the second part acid Jocko
overtly excluding my name Jocko what do
you do when you momentarily give into a
vice is something me and the way I see
this is that you do something about it
if you momentarily give in me if I
momentarily give in like no no let's
hear my advice because it probably
doesn't work oh because I thought you'd
say cuz it's just game over at that
point it is game over or you could take
it that the fact that they don't even
think you ever break yeah yeah but then
again you talk about anything just
leaves Oreo cookies on here so that's an
issue but to get down to it okay what
are your guilty pleasures guilty
pleasures number one first and foremost
mint chocolate chip ice cream and
especially mint chocolate chip ice cream
milkshakes and I do some twisted things
in my brain to kind of convince myself
that those are actually good for me yeah
and that they contain you just enough
carbs and there's some protein again and
there's some fat it's actually like a
full good meal which is just a big lie
cuz it's a big sugar bomb like a
supplement right so but I do I do
the I love mint chocolate chip ice cream
I really love chocolate milk - mm-hmm
and and there's been these articles
floating around the internet best
posting you didn't get and that's
another thing it's like okay but the
reality is it's sugar in milk and and
it's so again I'll I'll twist that one
in my head and sometimes for ten minutes
I'll convince myself that really that is
the right thing to do
obviously we've discussed on here before
those little damn pretzel wrapped
hotdogs that they serve in the airport
that have some kind of butter or
something on them that just damn yes
though I don't know who invented those
things but god bless them and then you
know you know the normal crap foods the
potato chips the french fries that
whatever the junk okay so am i immune to
the genetic evolutions that human beings
have been to through that make us desire
sugary foods and the endorphins going
off and firing out no I'm not immune to
those things when I and I'll tell you
when I do first of all I like to earn
those things right II
I either earn them on the front end or
the back end like one way or the other
like I either busted my ass and it did a
couple days of hard working out and all
of a sudden I'm you know I'm out with my
kid and we're swinging by and all of a
sudden I see there's like screams shop
the corner you know hey let's get a
little ice cream there's a little little
goat I'm and and one thing I when I do
it I don't like to have guilt yeah when
I'm sitting there oh no I'm not going oh
my god I can't believe I'm doing this
no I say man this is awesome oh this ice
cream milkshake tastes great that's
great but later on either that night or
the next day I earn that thing put a
little punishment in place little
punitive reprimand for slack behavior
and and I'll tell you the thing yet I'll
be careful of is that it is a slippery
slope and as you mentioned like one
potato chip
can lead to 20 and it does lead to 20
and even that is like okay understand we
had a we had a derailment right but
don't let one day of bad food lead to
another day of bad food and no working
out lead tuna that's what happens that's
what makes you saw off the rails and and
actually I mean there's like Tim Ferriss
he's got that thing where he does it's
something like six days in a row of
eating super clean and then on the
seventh day you actually is not just
cheetah you have to like just get after
it because your body has to get the
shock of carbs and all this stuff
there's another big lie like you can
tell you can twist your day he tells it
well you know to but you do have to be
careful of the slippery slope that for
me that's what that's what I think
happens I think I don't believe in this
stuff that you know you you use up your
willpower throughout the day and you use
if your discipline I believe that your
discipline decisions create more
disciplined decisions now if I do just
have a disaster of a day or if I have
let's say for whatever reason I have a
two day just gluttonous train wreck
binge where I'm just where I just for
whatever I lose the bubble you know and
there's could be anything any number of
things that could cause that maybe you
know it's like multiple I don't know bad
situation with travel than with an event
than with something that come home and
it's a birthday party and then anything
needs pizza and I'm like you know wanted
to hop and it's just done right is it
better to hold the line yeah it is mmm
but if I do have one of those situations
then I'll usually react to that you know
I'll earn it later I'll if I go on a
just a terrible food thing I'll do some
kind of a fast I'll do like a 24-hour
fast maybe in a 48 hour fast I haven't
done a 72 hour but I'm gearing up to do
a 72 hour what do you just you're
slaughter
yeah just drink water just drink water I
did the 48 hour
and it was actually nothing it was like
no problem no factor
I did everything normal squatted went
surfing did jujitsu there's some guys on
the mat and I said I'm stuck in a big
Eric you know big Eric and I was gonna
tell you something we got done train
this is after this is on the second day
of doing it and so we trained a bunch
and you know there's no factor and he
said what we gonna tell me I said I
haven't eaten for for 48 hours and I
said you know I'm just trying this out
and and I feel completely normal
you know so so that's that's one of the
things I'll do to recover now let's do
some kind of you know psycho kind of
hardcore workout you know we a body in
motion tends to stay in motion in the
body at rest tends to stay and rest
don't let the momentum start going the
wrong way you know what I mean get that
body back in motion get back on track
snap yourself back into the discipline
you know crush some workouts get after
it and get on that path the path of
discipline and strength and stay there
you mentioned the the keeping into the
brain that you are evolved to have or
whatever you know and that's like
seeking out sugar
yeah and fat and you know that's not bad
right but that's what you're evolved to
want and it's for a reason so you know
put simply back when you're a caveman
you didn't know when the next meal was
coming from yep so you know you get that
honey or that sugar that that needs much
calorie meal get it eat as much as you
can so your brain still like that so a
good tactic and I use this and it crazy
crazily it worked it worked for drinking
I mentioned this to you before uh uh
where you just understand that your
brain is in a way playing a trick on you
and if you give in literally by this
model you just fell for a trick and so
now you know that right so you're you're
falling for a trick yeah that is played
on you by your own brain because it
thinks it's you're still a caveman so
you see these donuts or cake or I don't
know pizza something delicious and fatty
you mean what you had for dinner tonight
yeah my dinner and your brains hey this
is one of those situations oh it's your
daughter's birthday party right you got
the family over what are you gonna do
put them all on a paleo diet for the
evening well tell me you can get em some
pizza and ice cream and it's all good no
but a cake for Echo Charles technically
those lunch and then I had a salad for
dinner okay good job see you back on the
track yeah like for that but so if you
you understand that you're you just fell
for a trick right there um so now I'm
going forward you know or okay if I have
these cravings or you know that donut
looks delicious and whatever way you're
gonna you're about to actively and
consciously fall for a trick right now
there is no scarcity of food right now
there's an abundance of food and you
know it's a perfect phrase for this
don't be a sucker
yeah right yeah it's like like like how
often is he like that's like the one the
worst thing someone can tell you that's
the one I in your view or a sucker
that's my work so that's why I worked
for you yeah don't be a sucker so don't
be a sucker to that piece of your brain
that's trying to trick you yeah indle
wanting stuff that's actually bad for
you yeah so yeah and so how the trick
works is your brain is saying hey those
donuts those are those are beneficial
and look at all these venez like you'll
get your calories you know knows when
they're gonna come that's what your
brain is that's how it feels they're
gonna come when you order Domino's yeah
yeah that's that's the reality but your
brains not telling you that yeah it's
giving you a Craig who's you need all
those calories you don't know what it's
gonna come and look at all these
benefits it's gonna taste good and this
is what you need that's what your brain
is telling you this is what you need but
the reality is you don't live in that
world anymore where you can get as many
donuts as you want now
so it's tricking you into thinking that
the short-term benefits are the benefits
when in reality since the world we live
in now is different the long-term
benefits are the benefits
yes and they don't involve Donuts or
don't thinking don't be a sucker
don't be a sucker yeah it helps man it
helps if you care about being a sucker
though that's the thing if you're like
it out there about being a second in it
there's no way
that's what I think do that's what I
think too